more than 1 million people in the
evacuation zones are moving away from
the coast Myrtle Beach South Carolina
reverse several highway lanes yesterday
so all the traffic can move inland David
Beck knows in Wrightsville Beach North
Carolina which is getting ready for a
possible direct hit David good morning
to you good morning Gail a mandatory
evacuation goes into effect here on
Wrightsville Beach at 8 a.m. and Gail
what's different about North Carolina is
that if you don't follow a mandatory
evacuation order here you can be cited
with a misdemeanor crime listen I just
got off the phone with the National
Hurricane Center and they sound subtly
ominous in tone when they give this
information right here in Wrightsville
Beach where I'm standing right now the
storm surge could be between 9 and 13
feet that is higher than some homes the
rainfall I'm told could be between 20
and 40 inches it is staggering when you
think of it on the beach where we are
right now all of these homes will be
under immediate mandatory evacuation and
it is these barrier islands of North
Carolina that will be the first to bear
the brunt of hurricane Florence the
weather is quiet it is beautiful for the
most part it appears as though most
people are starting to leave it's eerily
empty around here but people are being
warned if you haven't left now is the
time to get out it is an extremely
dangerous life threatening historic
hurricane North Carolina's governor Roy
Cooper issued a grim warning yesterday
as mandatory evacuations went into
effect
hurricane Florence will affect each and
every one of you I've been through one
the strong so you know safety first
people living in Wrightsville Beach are
bracing for a direct impact they got a
long trip for Phillip Payne it meant
packing up his truck and driving to
Charlotte with his fiance and two dogs
it's definitely going to get out of here
better safe than sorry as Florence
closes in stores in the Carolinas and
Virginia have already run out of fuel
groceries and generators yeah
in Raleigh North Carolina people waited
for hours for store managers to restock
the shelves at 6 o'clock this morning
10:30 now is the week yesterday we drove
through Myrtle Beach South Carolina
where it appeared most people had obeyed
warnings to get out
the Highway Patrol told us if people
stay in their homes and they don't heed
the evacuation and leave the cops are
not gonna pull them out of their house
but they may not be able to come and
help you if you need rescuing when the
storm makes landfall you're not worried
about staying behind no but there are
always those people like Mike white and
his eight neighbors who have stocked up
on essentials and planned a ride out
Florence ok which is well we are wishing
you and your neighbors well Mike look I
just got off the phone with our
meteorologist at our Charleston
affiliate in South Carolina and John
Bill Walsh that's the name of the
meteorologist told me he said David our
threat level has risen significantly as
the storm has started to jog a little
further to the south we are more worried
now than we were 24 hours ago please
everybody get ready people the the tone
that meteorologists are using is very
very serious yeah thank you David they
worry keeps rising